some advice I got some advice for
everybody when it comes to YouTube when
it comes to podcasting just don't like
just stop pointing at other people
yeah and start doing your thing yes you
know many you know many people do your
own thing you know many people try to
get me in drama with other people I get
emails all the time they're like dude
you see this guy I'm like I don't care
that it's spilling on me people are
hitting me up like yo Tim just did this
and I am so upset I'm just like keep
moving delete now I won't delete it
that's not what I'm looking for if you
if you want reality TV you gotta get it
somewhere else yeah it's not gonna be
here I mean actually Tim cast IRL is
literally the more personal like title
reality but I'm you know there there's
there's a ton of people who like make
videos about me and stuff and I've had a
ton of people try to get me to do live
shows and debates and stuff talking
about my family or whatever and I'm like
why would why is that relevant to anyone
else's life right it's not it wouldn't
fulfill me either if I hadn't if I had
two choices quit or do reality TV I'd be
like I'm go to the woods man got a
little Hut business so Whittle some
sticks so so but here's the advice
here's the advice like I'm adding to
what I said before folks on yourself
you're not gonna you're you're not going
to succeed crossing your fingers that
someone else is gonna interview you that
someone else is gonna debate you you
know you can't send a nasty message to
someone hoping that that's gonna get you
attention some people take the bait it's
not worth it
you know if you want to if you want to
succeed that this the secret is a
combination of first hard work second
you got to have you got to figure it out
you gotta have that knowledge you got to
find that opportunity and lastly a
little bit of luck yeah right place
right time right move but I like to do I
like to discount the luck thing it does
well at the same time though I I am a
perfect example of luck I happen to know
somebody that's not luck it's not that's
why I was gonna say it's not look how is
that now look I mean I have known you
for a long time we've exactly it's not a
lot like yeah but you know you you could
have hit up a couple of signature I
could have said no you could've
projected I not by chance I love this
I love you guys chance favors the
prepared yeah okay
the lock that you encounter as a result
of the decisions you made yep is it
preparedness is it like it's
preparedness yeah it's like getting
yourself you know knowledgeable about
things I mean it helps a lot yeah I
guess we've known each other for a long
time we tried doing a show before I and
I want to do this van thing it didn't
work out so much I had you up instead
and you were available he said let's do
it yeah but we had tried before so it's
I wouldn't call it luck I am I am pretty
lucky though I have had a blessed life
man I don't disagree dude my life I I'm
a lucky person I I do I love it I'm so
grateful for the opportunities I've had
and I yeah it's it's it's good I feel
lucky to be here and nothing you say can
change that you look at the comments
about about you and people are like oh
at first I didn't know I felt about you
know so I Jesus now now I'm seeing like
he's actually SOI chat or whatever like
he just went full Mogga but the fact is
first comes hard work yeah above
everything everything else second is the
knowledge the ability to do something
okay so you have clearly articulated
thoughts on a bunch of different things
yeah you're confident on camera you're
able to speak English well I'll tell you
what man whether you might not recognize
it because you're like this is easy I'm
just talking no I've done interviews
with people and it's like they stopped
talking immediately can't do it yeah all
right so it really is about it's a
combination of factors ultimately though
I think it's it's hard work uh luck is
real you know and the way I would
describe luck is just like sometimes
opportunity comes along for some people
yeah but more importantly luck is a
fraction of a fraction of success it's
true I will admit done right out right
place right time sure but I'll put it
this way you also got to commit you got
to do do the work let's put it this way
you go to a 7-eleven and you you find a
dollar in your pocket you like oh man I
got extra dollar and the clerk looks me
in the eye and says hey buddy you should
buy this lottery ticket and you go man
and you walk away and that lottery take
was a winning number you had the money
you were prepared you were given the
opportunity you rejected it it's not
luck that you chosen to take it maybe
you're headed with the dollar maybe you
would have chosen to buy and said wow
I'm so lucky well tons of
tons of people have thrown away lotto
tickets only to force I'm gonna find it
later and be like it's a winner there's
and then they try and get it back like
mine so I'll tell you what my advice you
want to do a show you want do a podcast
just start doing it yep
seriously everybody's like Matt have
your own thing you want to know how many
people me times I've gotten messages
from people asking me to connect them
with Joe Rogan yeah
dude no way that is the most
inappropriate thing everything I'm gonna
message that guy and be like yo this guy
randomly texted me and said he wants a
random person just hit me up and wants
to get to know oh yeah that'll work
sure yeah try to be nice by the way next
time you talk to him put in a good word
at all right I try to be nice and now
I'm like look man it's not that's not
how it works like I'll tell you what if
you actually got somebody I don't know
what what Joe's like reaction would be
to somebody messaging him like here's a
random person you should interview yeah
but I would imagine many people you
would hurt your chances of ever doing
anything with that show by asking a
random person like there are some things
that make sense and there are some
things that don't you know like for me
it was it was eight years ago knows nine
years ago some people were tweeting at
Joe to have me on the show and then Joe
responded that's about it and then he
canceled on me after I flew to LA yeah
and then the next year did the same
thing and then a few years later he
apologized yeah he's a cool dude but
then you were on the show and it was a
it was an awesome show and it was all
accidental it was I I did a segment
about I recorded a segment about what
happened with him and Jack Dorsey and I
kind of broke down a bunch of the things
that I thought were wrong with it and I
said you know I think we're slightly
better off for him having done the
interview but I don't think we got
anything really you know out of it yeah
and he copyright claimed it
automatically and so I'm looking at my
YouTube and it's like copyright claim
from this company now I'm like wait what
and I look and I'm like wait Joe because
I had a screenshot of the podcast so I
deemed him because he started following
me after he was like you I'm sorry about
you know canceling you before and then I
was like could you release this cuz like
this is like taking my ad money yeah he
was like sorry sorry about Days
automatic it happens you know I want to
add one thing to our conversation we
were just having
about that opportunity when that when
that teller comes to you and says I mean
obviously I'm just using your example
and says hey this is a winner winning
lotto ticket it's only a dollar but you
should take this opportunity when that
opportunity comes along like when Tim
hit me up and said hey you wanted to do
this show I didn't hesitate I said
absolutely I do I want to do that that
sounds awesome you knew what Jen I took
it I took the ticket you know and I want
and that's that's really the key it's
like is it luck or is it just finding
the right opportunity and that those
opportunities present themselves when
you do the research when you are
knowledgeable and you are doing the work
when you when you start your podcast and
you're just continuing doing it those
opportunities just start appearing but
here's the important point man it call
it me hitting you up wasn't a lot of
ticket you've done tons of camerawork
you had a career right right it's
obviously a much more than a lot of yeah
you're you're a lot of ticket it really
I don't even like that example I was
just using you're right right right
because they so it involves gambling if
I it's not really part of it if I needed
to get like my deck fixed and I called a
carpenter I knew yeah it's not luck it's
like I know a carpenter hey I need
someone to fix this this wood broke yeah
I'm right I'm right here yeah so I'm
like I need somebody who is comfortable
confident on camera like knows games and
pop-culture stuff now that's not a joke
about the SOI Jesus thing I am actually
a carpenter well there you go so uh
usually should do because we were
actually talking about overreach
government overreach yeah yeah and then
I kind of just went off on The Young
Turks I hate doing this I got to be
honest I really don't like talking about
say like The Young Turks or whatever
because you know it's like I mentioned
he brags about his viewership and how
important he is like man it's a bad look
you know it's funny he's like this is
not a good look for you man yeah yeah
but I really I really don't like doing
content about people that don't matter
and it's not like he matters in his own
right to his audience and to his
business and all that but he's not in
politics he tried when he when he did he
mattered will will this famous you know
personality win he didn't okay now he's
not doing anything so it's not that
important I I used them only in this
reference because he's an example of a
high profile progressive saying impeach
Trump
so yeah I begrudgingly mentioned you
know this has there's some people who
create what I would call like lower brow
content which is exactly what I just did
which is why I'm like regretting you
know regretting having done it I tried
warning it I know but you know but I
felt it's kind of like it's it's been
it's been stewing for a while when you
have these small channels they're bottom
feeders and what they do is they just
create shock content about low-tier like
you know it's funny men people who make
videos about me it's the funniest thing
ever because nobody knows who I am yeah
I know I've got a bunch of subscribers I
know there's people watching I'm not
trying to respect anybody but it's like
if you went to any major corporation I
mean how about this go look at the top
podcast on Apple I'm not there yeah not
there at all
you know is like venture Piro you know
steven crowder Rachel Maddow
Joe Rogan of course is number one you
know if you go to anybody in powerful
media they're gonna be like Tim who and
then you might show them something oh
I've never they can't be surprised no I
think you'd be surprised maybe ya know
ya know so when when people make content
about me it's like not only am i one of
like the weakest opinion people on
YouTube nobody cares
yes but its quality though quality
quality milquetoast opinion yeah thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you